tonight I ordered a targeted military
strike on the airfield in Syria from
where the chemical attack was launched
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for reason we're
talking with Emma Ashford of the Cato
Institute she holds a PhD in foreign
affairs from University of Virginia and
as an expert on the Middle East
Emma thanks for talking to us good to be
here President Donald Trump ordered
missile strike against a Syrian Air Base
what's the likely outcome of this action
with regard to the Syrian civil war and
to US relations with allies in the area
does something stands it depends where
this goes next this strike appears to be
something about a one-off the Trump is
portraying it as you know we are hitting
the Syrians hard a punitive action to
show them they can't use chemical
weapons which was the proximate cause
for the struck exactly that's at least
that's what the the Trump administration
is saying is that they they're carrying
this out because they believe preventing
chemical weapons use is in the US
national interest allies in the area and
the region have claimed that this is a a
welcome development but what they mean
by that is that they also want the Trump
administration to start taking a harder
line on the Assad regime and they would
like to see Trump take further action
against it so who are the allies in the
area that are pushing for that because
obviously Russia we assume we're not
quite an ally but in in this civil war
they are who's pushing for a harder line
or more engagement well the Russians are
actually pretty unhappy about this
development because the Russians thought
that the Trump administration would be
more open to a negotiated settlement the
people in the region who are happy are
the Saudis the Qataris the United Arab
Emirates to a lesser extent Turkey these
countries that have been pushing to get
Assad out for the last five six years
and they've been wanting US support that
whole time the Obama administration
didn't give it to them the question now
is whether the strike is a one-off or
whether Trump is actually going to
follow through on that it is in this
vital national security interest of the
United States to prevent and deter the
spread and use of deadly chemical
weapons
is he right about that it was a
difficult question right I mean I think
we all benefit from the the norm and
indeed the international law against
chemical weapons use but they're not
actually particularly good weapons of
war and if you look at the Syrian
situation the Assad regime killed less
than a hundred people in this chemical
weapons attack the other day they've
killed thousands hundreds of thousands
over the last six years and yet we don't
appear to find that to be a national
security interest or a problem for us
and so it's really again not clear
whether Trump thinks this is a
humanitarian intervention or whether he
thinks that it's a security intervention
does he think that we are threatened by
Syria should question should the u.s. be
doing humanitarian interventions in
Syria as opposed to and that's leaving
aside whether or not it is a security
one but absolutely not and I think it's
really instructive here to compare Obama
and Trump because they faced exactly the
same situation the Assad regime
attacking civilians with sarin gas and
they responded in very different ways so
Obama is often criticized that redline
that he made it was a really stupid
statement but he then went on and forged
this really successful diplomatic
compromise broad in the Russians they
removed the vast majority of the
chemical weapons and you'll notice that
for the time Obama was in office there
was no chemical weapons attack it's only
know that we have a new president that
the Syrians have decided to test this
norm and it you know I don't think a lot
of people were satisfied with with
Obama's stance towards Syria because it
was he said the redline and he was
pushing for it he got pulled back by
Rand Paul and Justin Amash and a couple
of other members of Congress but it's
clear also that going boots in is not a
good idea
what is the you know and and more
broadly in the Middle East we invaded
Iraq in 2003 we pulled out in 2011 or
combat troops we're still involved in
the area we're now in the third
president in in the 21st century they're
three for three of getting involved in
the Middle East what is the essential
lesson that presidents and both parties
as well as Democrats and Republicans
need to learn from
it you know it's a quagmire I mean we're
stuck in the Middle East what is the
essential lesson that we need to learn
that we have not yet mastered you know
if we go back to that Obama decision not
to intervene in Syria in 2013 I think
it's pretty clear that he had learned
the lessons of Iraq and particularly of
his own failed intervention in Libya
he looked both of those and he saw that
while the initial military action might
go well we end up creating more of a
problem than we actually solve and
there's there's actually good academic
evidence that probably more people died
in Libya as a result of the US
intervention than if we just had not
intervened in the first place so
whenever we intervene in these conflicts
we seem to make things worse when Obama
made his choice of chemical weapons he
said well a diplomatic compromise might
be imperfect but it's far better than
military strikes that will lead who
knows where Trump doesn't seem to have
that level of forethought he's made the
military strikes and who knows what the
next step is well we will leave it there
thank you we've been talking with Emma
Ashford of the Cato Institute for reason
I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]
you